bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
luís muñoz desde bogotá y me acompañan
gustavo petro candidato presidencial a
las elecciones presidenciales de
colombia junto a su fórmula
vicepresidencial
francia márquez que el próximo domingo
19 de junio se enfrentarán a rodolfo
hernández y su fórmula vicepresidencial
marilén castillo de ganar gustavo petro
sería el primer presidente de izquierda
de la historia de colombia una meta tras
un largo camino ya que ha sido ex
guerrillero del grupo m-19 también ha
sido congresista alcalde de bogotá y
este es su tercer intento electoral
muchas gracias gustavo petro por estar
en france 24 ha producido de ustedes
televidentes muy moles es evidente que
los colombianos piden un cambio es
evidente también que usted y francia-
márquez lo representan pero también hay
un sector de la sociedad que piensa que
rodolfo hernández y manel en castillo
pueden ser ese cambio esto cree que
dificulta sus opciones de lograr la
presidencia respecto a por ejemplo
haberse enfrentado a federico gutiérrez
el candidato de la derecha
pero mira la que uno analiza la votación
de la primera vuelta
geográficamente
encuentra respuestas la votación por
nosotros es
mayoritaria en las regiones más pobres
del país
y en la ciudad
y el caribe el pacífico bogotá la
votación por hernández es el mundo del
pequeño municipio andino
muy conservador
y entonces expresan dos visiones que no
son ambas del cambio
una proponga al cambio porque no
necesita a los sectores más excluidos
las juventudes y las regiones excluidas
que paradójicamente en colombia son las
que tienen más
y demuestra el centralismo andino
bogotano digamos que ha sido el mundo
del poder
y
un mundo andino que votó por uribe puede
usted colocar el mapa del voto por el sí
a la paz y el voto por el no a la paz y
la votación de rodolfo coincide con el
voto por el no a la paz que en ese
entonces fue mayoritario y la votación
nuestra por el tsja la paz entonces no
son dos opciones de cambio es una opción
de cambio enfrentada a una coalición
casi ya la última que se puede hacer de
fuerzas de derecha conservadora tratando
de mantener las cosas como están pero
usted sí que ha tenido un cierto cambio
hemos visto que a rodolfo hernández le
han funcionado muy bien las redes
sociales usted en la primera vuelta
utilizó mucha tarima mucho discurso
público y ahora se ha centrado en unas
retransmisiones en directo que hemos
estado viendo ha influenciado el
fenómeno hernández también en su campaña
no mal escrito
ganamos la primera vuelta es decir la
estrategia triunfadora fue la nuestra
que se hizo a partir de la plaza pública
de grandes multitudes de demostración de
fuerza de oratoria de propuestas hechas
en la plaza pública
el problema es que al final fueron
creciendo tanto las amenazas que ya las
manifestaciones tienen que hacerse casi
que con muro de brinda g que separaban
física y automáticamente y visualmente
la población de él
del candidato y a mí me pareció es una
imagen terrible y a
absolutamente contraproducente así que
hablar entre escudos brindados
ya incluso las palabras tenían
dificultad en salir cuando estás
esperando que te disparen
entonces eso me llevó a replantear
esa imagen fuerte de los escudos
blindados entre la población y el
candidato la candidata que francia marc
que le tocó hacer lo mismo debe ser
reemplazado por una humanización
y recordé mi forma de vivir de joven yo
vivía entre campesinos vivían entre
obreros entre gente excluida
y entonces retornar a eso a mí me servía
personalmente me sentía
refortalecido y hacia fuera digamos ver
como soy una persona que es capaz de
hablar con una señora
nos llevamos más excluida víctima la
violencia en un barrio muy pobre de
quibdó la región quizás más de excluida
de colombia
y eso
no solo me llenaba de fuerzas nunca hay
que verlo transmite un mensaje un tanto
diferente que los muros brindados
esperando un disparo
esas amenazas también implican como un
fuerte odio hacia figura dentro de la
sociedad incluso también un temor usted
cree que tiene la fuerza suficiente
ahora para vencer a ese anti petr ismo y
como si en caso de ganar cómo va a
gobernar con también una parte de la
sociedad tan virulenta hacia esa figura
en general el anti pec turismo es la
otra cara de la misma humanidad que es
el uribismo
o sea en general una persona fuertemente
uribista es fuertemente anti petrista
producto de prácticamente la lucha
política de este siglo
él lo que hemos logrado es disminuir ese
anti petr ismo que se funda en dos
grandes pilares el miedo y la mentira
que básicamente en todo el mundo son los
pilares de programas de la extrema
derecha un miedo que construyen porque
sobre eso es que han podido obtener el
voto
entonces el miedo al cambio
el miedo al progresismo el miedo a las
reformas de cara a la justicia social
y la mentira entonces sobre la mentira
las campañas fuertemente financiadas y
difundidas en redes mostrándome como un
expropiador como un comunista como quien
va a quemar las iglesias como otro
maduro cosas así
y cuando juntas miedo y
mentir a veces encuentras que han ganado
elecciones así destruyeron la paz de
colombia sí y hoy creo que la diferencia
es que ese miedo y esa mentira que son
más pequeños no son minoritarios eso es
lo que me da la oportunidad de ganar
usted también va a tener que representar
a esa gente que obviamente estamos
proponiendo un gran acuerdo nacional
incluso invitaría a álvaro uribe vélez a
sentarse allá en el palacio nariño
conmigo para construir primero otro
clima que no sea no lo que no existan
diferencias porque siempre las va a
haber sino que no se tramiten a partir
del sectarismo y el odio y en segundo
lugar para lograr consensos alrededor de
unas reformas sociales que el país
necesita urgentemente
para poder precisamente convivir en paz
para construir justicia social además de
esta reunión de ganar cuáles son sus
tres primeras decisiones como presidente
el hambre ha aumentado en colombia de
una manera excepcional por problemas
mundiales por problemas internos de mala
política económica que acabó con nuestra
producción de alimentos y de
fertilizantes importados con la
devaluación enorme del peso y con los
problemas de guerra en el mundo pues ha
provocado un estallido del hambre que
afecta de manera
muy grave la primera infancia
entonces la primera tarea es reducir el
hambre ojalá llegar hambre cero para eso
me propongo una serie de medidas
urgentes
consisten en compras cosechas por vender
directamente en el barrio popular donde
está el hambre a bajo precio o instalar
mecanismos de alimentación gratuita
subsidiar la importación de
fertilizantes hasta que los podamos
producir ya un poco de media plazo para
abaratar la producción de alimentos en
colombia en colombia estamos en una
crisis alimentaria no tanto porque no
existan los alimentos están en el
supermercado sino que son han crecido en
su precio de una manera exagerada
comparada con el crecimiento de los
ingresos y entonces cada vez más
familias tienen dificultad en
alimentarse la pobreza ha llegado ya en
las estadísticas oficiales a casi el 40
por ciento de la población
entonces estamos en una catástrofe
social
por eso realizamos la voluntad de cambio
que se expresa en la política lo que se
ha desplomado es una visión del mundo y
una un sistema económico que ya no es
sostenible se ha votado y ha llevado a
la sociedad colombiana a una crisis
integral incluso ética
y la percepción de la mayoría de la
sociedad es querer cambiar eso
nosotros hemos hecho una propuesta para
eso pero te decía la primera política la
lucha contra el hambre
otro de los retos en colombia es también
en el cultivo de coca que se supone que
es como un 2% del pib de colombia
como va a combatir el hecho de que
colombia sea una potencia de la
industria de las drogas ilícitas en el
mundo
pues la responsabilidad está en los
países consumidores
porque la mafia se acaba si ellos
legalizan las drogas
no lo quieren hacer muchas razones de
política interna en esos países que se
los impide
entonces a nosotros nos corresponde
un diálogo con los eeuu de cara a volver
más eficaz la política antidrogas porque
es un rotundo fracaso después de 40 años
de implementarse hoy las mafias son más
fuertes hoy la exportación de cocaína es
mayor hoy más norteamericanos mueren ya
por el uso de otras drogas mucho más
peligrosas multiplicado casi por 20 el
número de muertes anuales por sobredosis
hoy un millón de la tiene un
latinoamericano fue asesinado en medio
de la guerra de las drogas
el balance no tiene ninguna cifra
positiva eso significa pragmáticamente
que los jefes de los gobiernos y los que
hacen la política
en este campo de eeuu y colombia deben
reunirse y variar la política antidrogas
hacia una más eficaz
la propuesta mía tiene que ver con que
la droga creció en colombia como
producto de exportación porque aquí
aniquilamos la producción industrial y
agraria y no hubo otra alternativa luego
si incrementamos la producción
y agraria industrial el campo de la
producción de cocaína disminuye si
logramos hacer una reforma agraria que
le permita más oportunidades al
campesinado pues el número de campesinos
dedicados a producir pasta de coca
disminuye si logramos que la economía
popular que es un concepto un poco poco
conocido en europa que es el mundo
digamos del cuenta propia de
del rebusque le decimos nosotros de una
cano mía que en general no es
capitalista sino que es el intento de
por lo menos conseguir un plato de
comida a través del esfuerzo propio en
el comercio en las calles en la
microempresa completamente informal esa
economía está haciendo
digamos tiene un sistema de crédito que
proviene de la mafia
porque la banca tradicional y clásica no
llega a ese tipo de familias que son la
mitad de colombia
bueno es la mafia lo hace a través del
voto gota un sistema de crédito usurero
para lavar dólares y cobra los créditos
con el revólver al cinto
un sistema de banco pública y de banca
cooperativa reemplaza ese control que
hoy tienen las organizaciones multi
crimen sobre la economía popular y de
esta manera
digamos aislar y amos núcleos de
población muy grandes que han estado
dependiendo
incluso por fuera de su voluntad de las
organizaciones multi crimen de ellas esa
es una manera de debilitar la
organización múltiplemente es quitarle
el poder político
de habilitadas son golpe hables o se
pueden auto desmantelar a partir de una
política de sometimiento la justicia
qué énfasis va a tener gustavo petro a
la hora de implementar los acuerdos de
paz y también poco después de las
elecciones del próximo 19 de junio si es
presidente recibirá el informe de la
comisión de la verdad cómo lo va a
recibir
primero los acuerdos firmados ya se
cumplen
los procesos a medio hacer que quedaron
suspendidos se continúan voy a reconocer
los protocolos que firmó colombia con
países como la comunidad internacional
para propiciar esos diálogos de paz que
fueron suspendidos por el actor gobierno
en tercer lugar abrimos las opciones de
una paz integral que siempre comienza
por abrirle las oportunidades de la vida
a la sociedad colombiana todas
la comisión de la verdad y dará su
informe y será
publicado por el mismo gobierno si yo lo
encabezó de tal manera que ese trabajo
se ha conocido ojalá por la total y la
totalidad de la sucio de columbia
hablaba antes de eeuu
históricamente los gobiernos de colombia
y eeuu han sido grandes aliados que
cambiará en su política frente a eeuu
como presidente incluyendo
que propongo
comienza por el tema la crisis climática
en américa toda
hay que comprender de europa que américa
una vez de alaska hasta la patagonia
hay un gran emisor de co2 el factor de
la que produce la crisis climática que
es eeuu
y hay una gran esponja de las mayores
del planeta que absorbe co2 que es la
selva amazónica ahí hay un diálogo que
hacer
porque si queremos la vida de la
humanidad del gran emisor y la gran
esponja tienen que dialogar
hay que salvar la selva amazónica ese es
un tema
hay propuestas concretas para ello pero
es un tema que tiene que plantearse en
un nuevo diálogo entre el gobierno de
los eeuu y el nuevo gobierno progresista
de colombia el segundo tema es reconocer
el fracaso de la política antidrogas
hasta ahora llevada a los números lo
indican si el gobierno ha estado unidos
me demuestra con números que no ha
fracasado pues pues discutimos pero
sobre los números
y si se reconoce eso entonces cuál sería
la política más eficaz
la política antidrogas en colombia y ese
es un segundo tema que hay que discutir
lo que nos lleva necesariamente si
reconocemos que entre menos producción
haya en colombia del área industrial más
cocaína fluía eeuu
y que por tanto lo que hay que hacer es
aumentar
en la producción de alimentos en
colombia la producción industrial
entonces hay que mirar si el tlc el
libre comercio ayuda en ese propósito o
no
gabriel boric fue el último en chile
usted puede ganar el domingo también
puede ganar lula en brasil hay como una
nueva ola de gobiernos de izquierda en
américa latina' puede haber propuestas
comunes que propondría usted para este
los nuevos gobiernos proyecto méxico
son economías poderosas yo creo que se
podría entregar la argentina y bolivia
la idea que propongo no es que
estoy muy convencido de ello pluralidad
que propongo es que no se puede repetir
la historia reciente del progresismo que
ha gobernado y que acabo de dejar el
poder que se cimentó en la exportación
de petróleo carbón y gas natural
esa esa historia no era sostenible
por la crisis climática
y por tanto el nuevo progresismo tiene
que saber llevar américa latina-asia una
visión diferente
que es
construir producción cimentada en el
conocimiento
construir agricultura y entonces tenemos
que hablar de reformas agrarias
construir industria entonces tenemos que
hablar de conocimiento de conectividad
de energías limpias de descarbonización
de la economía y eso genera una agenda
diferente a la que se tenía hace 20 años
inventada exclusivamente en sostener el
precio elevado a las materias primas
usted habla de finalizar las
exploraciones de petróleo sin embargo
colombia es autosuficiente
energéticamente y esto tal vez en estos
momentos de crisis energética global le
ha permitido tener un poco más de aire
cómo va a poder hacer esa transición
no perderlo
porque colombia tiene una potencialidad
de energías limpias
sol vientos agua
de hecho el 60% de nuestra materia
energética ya es agua
simplemente es hacer la transición sin
perderla sobre la nieve
más difícil es la descarbonización de
los sectores productivos la
electrificación del transporte poder
empezar porque no tenemos nada
una red seria
pasaron transporte eléctrico poder
utilizar al máximo las tierras fértiles
que tenemos disponibles en producción
alimentaria poder extender el sistema de
la universidad pública al conjunto de la
juventud porque al final es la ciencia y
los saberes en general la base de la
producción
la ciencia existe porque había
producción en la humanidad
y eso digamos esa correlación nos mueve
hacia reformas son tanto complejas en
estos terrenos que queremos comenzar a
abordar porque es una transición la
economía petrolera no nos deja
primero nos lleno de corrupción el flujo
de dólares que diez veces más que
nuestra anterior economía que era la
cafetera lo que se convirtió fue también
en un volumen similar de importaciones
de cosas que podíamos producir en
colombia entonces dimos al traste unos
puestos de trabajo vimos al traste con
la agricultura en la industria creció el
narcotráfico la corrupción estatal casi
que armada así que sanguinaria se
extendió el país entró en una crisis
integral que con la caída del precio
internacional del petróleo antes de la
guerra ucrania y soya
metástasis
los efectos ahora son un enorme déficit
fiscal muy grande para nuestra historia
y un crecimiento del hambre como hacía
mucho tiempo colombiano vivió volviendo
a las elecciones ya dos preguntas para
terminar quería preguntarle jon lee
anderson el periodista estadounidense
hablaba que el eje izquierda-derecha
tradicional en américa latina en las
últimas elecciones había pasado a un eje
democracia autoritarismo crees que
estamos ante eso de cara a este 19 de
exactamente
el pueblo colombiano no maneja las
variables de izquierda a derecha
no es propia digamos en el imaginario
popular eso no existe
y a veces esa mirada falsear un poco los
comportamientos políticos de colombia
lo que hoy tenemos es un gran campo
democrático buscando cambios buscando
aplicar la constitución del 91
y espero sea mayoritario y un campo que
trate de impedirlo y que está cimentado
en ideas
que aplauden incluso el surgimiento de
dictadores
de violaciones de derechos humanos
creyendo que ese camino que conduce a la
seguridad es un discurso obviamente de
derechas y extremas pero las personas
que creen en eso no se sienten a sí
mismas ni derechas ni tampoco ven en la
contraparte de las izquierdas son
creencias más que todo que están
dividiendo el campo político colombiano
en democracia y anti democracia y
considera que rodolfo representa la
antidemocracia obviamente una persona
que se jactó en no leer nunca un libro
una persona que sé no sé cómo lo podrás
decir en francés
le importa aún
la ley
ser tú
que considera que el puesto de las
mujeres es la cocina
y lo práctica demás
que digamos de
él es un multimillonario sin leer un
libro ese tipo es esa fortuna la ha
hecho a través de la política a pesar de
que ha vendido la idea de la anti
corrupción hoy está en un proceso
judicial en dos procesos judiciales que
si llegase a ser presidente de acuerdo a
las normas colombianas quedaba
suspendido de inmediato porque ya no
está en una fase de investigación sino
está en una fase de juicio por
corrupción este digamos es ese
planteamiento
de ese tipo de personas con las cuales
una parte de la sociedad con genia
porque así ha sido en todo este siglo y
no representa valores democráticos
destruiría jueces
y en curso el debate parlamentario de
hecho no asistió a ningún debate
presidencial no puede
asumir el debate
simplemente porque no podría expresar
ideas
para terminar usted ha dicho que no hay
neutralidad en la registraduría aceptará
los resultados en caso de perder y
confía en el sistema
golpes contra la transparencia electoral
porque no confío en el sistema electoral
colombiano de hecho y ante el fallo del
máximo organismo judicial
el consejo de estado en el contencioso
administrativo se ordenó que el software
de escrutinio de los votos fuese
propiedad al estado para que pudiera ser
auditado técnicamente que no tuviera
algoritmos maliciosos etcétera a la
fecha y ha estudiado a tres días de
elecciones no se nos permitió hacer la
auditoría porque se incumplió la
sentencia
y hoy tienen es un software alquilado
desde hace 20 años de una empresa
privada que no permite la auditoría no
hay garantías
ojalá no nos encontremos evidencias de
que se alteró el software pero pero no
se puede confiar cuando no te permiten
la auditoría técnica
muchas gracias gustavo petro por estar
en france 24
a todos ustedes muy hombres y muchas
gracias también a nuestra audiencia
pueden seguir más contenidos como este
en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
[Música]